hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to tell
edition of ask Evan today we're going to
be continuing in our challenge series
and going to be answering a question
from one of our telescopes business
Facebook fans named Joey who wrote in
about his business asking hello do you
have any info or helpful advice to boost
a home-based business please i've
advertised upper promos called clients
but things seem to have shifted a bit
what else can i do or is it just a
waiting game thank you so thank you the
question Joey a great question that a
lot of home-based and startup
entrepreneurs go through starting a
business one of the hardest things that
you're ever going to do it's always
going to take longer than you think it
will but congrats on getting it started
and here are three tips to help you grow
it to the next step number one hustle
while you wait Thomas Edison once said
everything comes to those who hustle
while they wait it couldn't be more true
for entrepreneurs building a business
does take time a lot more time than you
ever thought it would before you start
it up but you can't afford to just wait
you have to keep taking action while
you're waiting on other people to get
back to you do something every day to
grow your business and pretty soon those
small steps will turn into giant leaps
forward
here's an example from Joyce Clyde Hall
who was a founder of hallmark the
success of hallmark as an
internationally recognized company is a
testament to Hall's hard work beginning
with the days where Hall would take the
train by himself far out into the
countryside to see if there was any
interest in his cards Hall recognized
the value of taking action even wear it
meant nothing more than often tiresome
legwork according to haul I don't just
like to sit around and wait for
something to happen it's more fun making
it happen I figured I wasn't as smart as
some of the other fellows so I had to
work twice as hard number to partner up
one of the fastest ways to grow business
is to find someone who is already
selling to your target market and
partner up with them it doesn't mean you
have to give up outputting in your
business just find a way you can help
each other out maybe they get a
commission maybe you can help promote
them or maybe you have a skill that they
need and you can trade partner with your
direct competition usually doesn't work
but think about where your customers go
before they buy from you and after they
buy from you those are businesses that
you need to partner up with they sell
complementary products and services to
the same people that you serve make a
list and start reaching out here's an
example from Ty Warner who was founder
of beanie babies in the spring of
nineteen ninety-seven Warner made his
first venture into conventional
marketing when he joined up with
McDonald's for one of the most
successful promotions ever in the
history of both companies for five weeks
McDonald's customers would be given one
of ten Warner toys with the purchase of
every McDonald's Happy Meal smaller in
size in the original beanie babies these
toys were called teeny beanies Warner
explaining his decision to partner with
McDonald's would exploit the potential
for reaching new markets according the
Warner we really did it to expand our
product to children who wouldn't be
shopping in upscale shopping malls we
some mcdonalds as the best avenue to get
these kids to see them number three get
to know your customers part of the
appeal for many people who start
home-based businesses is that they're
trying to create a semi-automated new
income stream especially when you're
first starting up you need to invest
your energy to get to know the people
who are buying from you
how did they find you what are the needs
do they have are they happy with what
they bought from you the more you get to
know them the better you'll be able to
serve them and build your business
providing excellent service with a
personal touch will also lead to more
referrals and repeat purchases take the
time to call all your customers and get
to know them and why they're buying from
you don't pester them a beer resource
and show you care and they'll reward you
with a steady stream of business here's
an example from Dave Thomas is the
founder of Wendy's in the early days
Thomas spent all his free time visiting
as many hamburger stands and restaurants
as he could in order to learn what he
could from them and use that knowledge
to his advantage no detail was too small
to look after from the food to the
service of the atmosphere inside a
Wendy's Thomas wanted everything to be
better than the best Thomas made
customer satisfaction is number one
priority and focus on quality in order
to ensure this according to Thomas
whether you sell hamburgers or computers
were all in the customer service
business our goal must be to exceed our
customers expectations every day
thank you for joining me for another
edition of ask Evan if you like the
video you want to see more please give
it a thumbs up below it makes you want
to do more of these videos for you and I
love to hear we have to think if you
have some advice for jewelry or if you
have your own question for your business
maybe we'll profile you in one of these
challenge posts so thank you and we'll
see you on the next episode
you
you